hi good morning everyone
i'm dr julie angster-melny with medical
and scientific affairs at roche
diagnostic corporation
so on april 25th 2014
the rosh cobus hpv test received fba
approval
as a first-line primary screening test
for cervical cancer
and so what this talk or what i'm here
to present is just some data around
the cobas test for primary screening
and provide a little bit of background
around this this new indication
i will be taking questions at the end of
the presentation so feel free to uh
write them down
as they come to your mind um and
with that welcome
so the concept of utilizing exfoliated
psychology to identify women with
invasive cervical cancer was first
introduced introduced by papa nicolas in
the 1920s
but it wasn't until the 1950s
following refinement of the technique
that it was demonstrated that
conventional cytology could also be used
to identify pre-cancerous lesions and
cervix and has the potential to actually
prevent the development of
cervical cancer
this technique is still in use today
and in fact is the most common method
used in the united states and also
abroad
in
1975 acog published the first u.s wide
recommendations for annual
testing for women 18 years and older
as a means to screen for cervical cancer
and it wasn't until the late
1880s that the link between hpv and
cervical cancer was established
and not until 1995 where the
international agency for research of
cancer actually classified
hpv 16 and 18 as carcinogenic
and concluded that hpv infection is a
necessary cause of cervical cancer
that
in 1999 we saw the first fda-approved
hpv test
and since then
we've seen that cervical cancer
guidelines or cervical cancer screening
guidelines
continue to have evolved to provide
data-driven recommendations that
highlight the preferred method of
screening
inc that includes hpv testing
and since the widespread adoption
following the 1975 acog recommendations
it did allow for quick and early
reduction in cervical cancer incidence
and mortality
but despite the the launch of the first
fca approved tests in 1999 and the
increasingly stronger recommendations
around the utilization of hpd testing
and cervical cancer screening adoption
remains fairly low even today
this has led to a leveling off on the
incidence of cervical cancer in the last
decade as there are several limitations
that still exist by using a
psychology-based screening method
so one of the main
limitations around the psychology-based
screening
program for the detection of cervical
cancer
is that cytology is very subjective and
this leads to intra and interlaboratory
variability
as part of the false trial the national
cancer institute had about 5 000
psychology slides re-read by second side
of pathologists
here you can see the results of
of that
analysis and on the left side of this
table you see what the original
diagnosis was
and along the top
you see what the second reviewer's
diagnosis was
um what we do see is that about 78
percent of the known cytology
was reclassified as known by the second
cytopathologist
not surprising
about 43 percent of the original ascus
calls were confirmed
which really highlights the fact that
this still is a very equivocal
uh psychological uh grade
but what was surprising is that 47
of the h cell cases
were reclassified as a is h cell upon
review
and again this really highlights the
fact that psychology is not very
reproducib reproducible
in addition from the athena study here
are the four labs that performed
psychology
readings
these four labs represent the labs that
perform about 25
of all cytology
in the united states today
along these four labs what we see is
that the median age for the women
included in this study did not change
from lab to lab
and the age of a woman is really what
dictates or is one of their
main
factors in abnormal psychology reading
so despite
the similar median age what we see is
that this aspect rate or the abnormal
rates per path actually varied quite
dramatically between the four labs from
a low of about 3.8 abnormal pulse to a
high of about 9.9 percent
what we also saw is that because of this
range in abnormalities
the sensitivity of cytology also varies
from 42 to 73
and that's not surprising considering
the higher the abnormal cause
the more likely disease will be detected
upon
coposcopy
and so the higher sensitivity of
cytology
is related to the higher rate of
abnormal cost
again
highlighting the subjectivity of of
cytology
across these four labs what we also saw
is that the sensitivity of the cobalt
hpv test
did not vary
tremendously
we also know that cytology has a very
limited sensitivity for c ion2 or
greater lesions
so here are two audits one performed by
kaiser permanente and one in sweden
and in these studies there was a
analysis looking at
uh women diagnosed with invasive
cervical carcinoma
and what the audit aim to do was to look
at what their recent
screening histories were of these women
not surprisingly
about 60 percent of women
that had invasive cervical carcinoma had
not been screened within the last five
years
but more surprising is about a third or
a quarter of the women
that did have invasive cervical
carcinoma
had been screened in the last five years
and
had a normal cytology result
in addition as part of the uspstf
uh
literature review and before making
their recommendations in 2012
they performed an analysis looking at
the variable sensitivity of psychology
and also the sensitivity of hpv dna
testing
what they found was that on average hpv
dna testing actually increased the
sensitivity
for high grade disease by about 36
percent over the sensitivity of
psychology
another limitation to psychology and
psychology-based screening is that it
does not establish risk
what psychology is extremely good at is
actually identifying
cervical cancer or cervical cancer
precursors
at the time of um
or at the time of uh infection
or analysis but it doesn't establish
whether or not a woman will develop
these
lesions or these high grade for this
high grade disease within the upcoming
screening interval
we know that hpv is the necessary cause
of cervical cancer and in fact about 70
of all cervical cancers are actually
associated with only two genotypes
and these are hpv 16 and 18.
in addition
what we know is that
by testing for hpv and especially
genotyping 16 and 18 we're also able to
identify women at risk for developing
high grade disease
this was a study done out of kaiser
following about 20 000 women varying
psychology grades for about a 10-year
period
what they saw was depending on the hpv
status at baseline
uh women were
were actually stratified by varying
risks
so that women with an hpv 16 positive
result were actually at a very high risk
of developing a cin3 or greater lesion
within this 10-year period
and this was even noted that at the
the
my arrow got a little short
that even within about a year from the
initial hpv-16 positive results
uh close to 10 of women actually had a
high grade lesion
this was slightly lower or
for hpv 18
but again towards the end of the 10-year
study you saw that the risk between the
two were actually much higher than the
risk associated with any other of the
12
or with the other 12 high-risk hpv
genotypes
additionally when a woman tested hpv
negative
at baseline regardless of the psychology
result
the risk of developing a high grade
lesion was extremely low reaching less
than one percent over the one of the
10-year period
in addition to these psychology-based
screening is highly complex especially
when combined with an hpv result
cytology has several varying grades
including the gnome ascus alpha and h
cell but there's also atypical squamous
cells cannot exclude h cell several
types of glandular abnormalities and
three categories to describe specimen
quality
and due to this complexity clinicians
have about 12 different management
algorithms just to manage psychology
results
and when combined with
an hpv result you can see by these
various diagrams
but the algorithms themselves are highly
complex and they're actually so complex
that clinicians who don't specialize in
cervical disease are finding them
difficult to use
and in fact navigating these does
require having cheat sheets slide rules
and even smart phone apps
so within the last month or so the fda
approved the first hpv test
to be used as a first-line primary
screening for cervical cancer
the aim of this is to not only
limit reduce some of the limitations
associated with psychology-based
screening but also to simplify overall
screening and management practices
the kobas hpv test
um has an additional intended use
um and so this is the intended use
statement
uh
that was that's in the package insert
for the cobas test
and basically just to summarize or
provide a high level
of intended use statements it is
approved for women 25 years and older to
be used as a first-line primary cervical
cancer screening test to detect high
risk hpv including genotyping for 16 and
18.
as part of this approval
or it was approved with an algorithm in
mind
and although the guidance documents and
guideline updates are pending hpv primer
screening may simplify screening and
also enhance current screening practices
relying on psychology so with this
algorithm for primary screening the most
sensitive test is used first which is
the hpv test to identify women at risk
of underlying high grade disease
hpv testing also removes the
subjectivity of screening
and produce providing greater
reproducibility and less
variability and positive calls
and with the three-in-one testing design
of the cobus hpd test
women are immediately stratified based
on risk of having or developing high
grade disease within the screening
interval
so the algorithm that was approved by
the fda
is as listed right here and just to kind
of walk you through it
uh women testing hpv negative are
followed up
with appropriate methods and screening
intervals
those testing hpv 16 are 18 positive
so these women would be at the highest
risk of high grade disease or be
referred for immediate composition
and those women
positive for the 12 other high-risk hpv
genotypes but which are eight who are
hpv 16 or 18 negative would be triaged
with psychology journaling the presence
of an underlying hybrid disease
those are abnormal psychology results
would be referred to colposcopy
and those with
negative psychology would also be
followed up in an appropriate screening
interval
so with this algorithm there's an
integrated balance between sensitivity
offered by the by the hpv test and also
specificity
uh with the integrated 16-18 genotyping
and also the triage utilizing cytology
for
for the other high-risk hpv-positive
results
so that not every woman testing hpv
positive would be referred to for
immediate coposcopy but really only the
right woman at the highest risk would be
so the first question that really came
to mind when when discussing the primary
screening algorithm and primer screening
in general
is at what age should the screenings
begin
we know that hpv infections are very
common in younger women
and they also tend to be much more
transient
however what we also see is that there
is a high burden of cin3 in women 25 to
29. and that psychology does perform
poorly specifically in young women as
opposed to older women
and what we also need to remember that
the point or the main objective of
cervical cancer screening is to prevent
cervical cancer in the first place
here is a
data set from the serotumor registry
looking at the invasive cervical cancer
rates in the u.s
what we can see is that starting at
about age 25 the incidence of cervical
cancer
dramatically increases to a peak at
around 35 to 39.
ideally what we want to do is identify
the cervical cancer precursors before
they lead to
cervical cancer
which means that we should probably
start looking for pre-cancer
in the age group 25 to 29 to prevent
this rise in cervical cancer incident
but we also need to establish what the
burden of disease is in this younger age
group
if these younger this young population
has very little disease screening all of
these women would be
fruitless
as we would just be sending a tremendous
number of women to poposcopy without
much benefit in detecting a disease
here is the data from athena
it is looking at the all cin3 or greater
lesions detected
and it's just distributed by age
what we see in that for women 25
and old or older
about a third of all cin3 cases detected
in athena were found in women 25 to 29
and in fact
the proportion of this
or the number they see in three
were much higher
so
a third of the disease was found in
about 6 600 women aged 25 to 29
versus
all the disease found in women 40 and
older
which was about 22 000 women
so this represents
about a four and a half fold higher
disease burden in the younger age group
than the older
and additionally given the small number
of women or the relatively small number
of women 25 to 29
uh compared to all other age groups the
proportion of ci increases actually the
highest in this age group than any other
age group
and lastly when evaluating at what age
to begin screening
we must evaluate the current screening
practices
and for women 25 to 29 this is cytology
alone
and we also have to establish whether
they are adequately or this
standard of care is adequate adequately
detecting disease within this age group
in athena
about 57
of women 25 to 29
with the iron three or greater had a
negative cytology result
and this is much higher than what was
seeing in any other age group
this suggests that the current
psychology-based screening is
ineffective in detecting pre-cancer in
women 25-29
so at this point we've established that
current screening practices have their
limitations and also have highlighted
the need to improve screening in women
25 to 29.
based on the size and scope of the
landmark athena trial we're able to
compare various screening app strategies
and evaluate the performance of the
cobox hpv test
when used as a first-line primary
screening test so the data i'm about to
present
was presented to the fda microbiology
devices advisor committee on march 12
2014
leading to the fda approval
and during this meeting the panel voted
39-0 in favor
in favor on three general measures
one was the safety of the primary
screening algorithm
efficacy and also
the fact that benefits would outweigh
the harm
especially compared to a psychology
based screening
program so what we'll be talking about
um predominantly is looking at the
sensitivity and specificity of the
primary screening algorithm
we'll be looking at the predictive
values positive predictive and negative
predictive values
as measures of effectiveness
what we'll also be talking about is the
safety
again this can be measured by the
negative predictive value
but also looking at the three-year
cumulative incidence risks for negative
results
because
most importantly when relying on hpv
testing or a new screening algorithm we
need to establish safety of a negative
result
in all these data you would be using
cim3 as an endpoint
because it really is the best surrogate
for cancer since it is
the immediate pre-turn precursor to
cervical cancer
it also has a very low likelihood of
regression
and really it it's a disease stage which
is
almost always treated
so to talk about the fit um
effectiveness of the primary screening
algorithm we'll be talking about mainly
the
the baseline athena study
and about the 41 000 women that were 25
years and older
um in in the athena study
of those about 8 000 women were triaged
to colposcopy at this baseline phase
uh the main comparator in all these data
sets is cytology alone
uh basically women who test negative
would be referred back to routine
screening while those with ask us or
greater would be referred to colposcopy
this is the primary screening algorithm
i'm not going to walk you through these
things in great detail at this point but
essentially it does uh include a
triage of 12 other high-risk hpv
positive results which with cytology
and hpv 16 and 18
as part of the initial triage for
coposity
so the kovac test design
it has a three in one function
so basically it has an integrated 16 and
18 genotyping so women are immediately
either given a result for the 12 other
high risk hpv genotypes as a pooled
result as well as an individual result
for 16 and an individual result for hpv
18
and also
beta globin is used as an internal
cellular control
just to ensure that there's uh
there's actually cellular material in
the collection and the sample itself
so when comparing the hpv primary
screening what we see is that uh when
compared to cytology hpv primary
screening increases the sensitivity by
about 37
and it also maintains the same relative
specificity
this is because we're using the hpv test
as in the initial test
which
elevates the sensitivity but with this
particular algorithm
what we're able to do is also offer high
level specificity
and then we see for the detection of c
in three or greater the positive
predictive value of the hpv primary
screening strategy is about 12
which is nearly twice that of phytology
alone and this indicates an improved
measure of effectiveness
as as women testing positive are more
likely to have disease
the negative predictive value is also
improved with an hpv primary screening
strategy compared to cytology
which indicates a higher measure of
safety as women who test negative with
this strategy can be given more
reassurance that they don't have high
grade disease the women who test
negative cytology
another comparator that we'll use is the
co-testing hybrid
and so this is a little bit complex
because
what it does is breaks down the
screening
scenarios based on age and this is
um in line with current guidelines
uh so women 25 to 29 are
utilized as psychology-based screening
but also has have an ascus
triage in which women with ascus
psychology
are sent for an hpv test and only if
they are hpv-positive
will they be referred to
colposcopy
for women 30 years and older
the latest cervical cancer screening
guidelines
hpv and cytology protesting was the
preferred method of cervical cancer
screening again this is only for women
30 years and older in this scenario
both the hpv test and the psychology
dictate what the management and
follow-up strategy should be
so when we compare
hpv primary screening
with this co-testing hybrid that
incorporates genotyping
what we see is that this obviously does
increase the sensitivity over cytology
alone
but hpv primary screening maintains a
higher level of sensitivity for the
detection of cin3 or greater
this is predominantly due to the fact
that the co-testing hybrid seen here
um
has the benefit of hpv testing only for
women 30 years and older so women 25 to
29
are still
screened with cytology alone
or cytology-based screening
which really reduces the overall
sensitivity of this particular algorithm
when we look at the positive predictor
values and the negative predictive
values again we see that the co-testing
hybrid with genotyping does increase the
positive predictive value over cytology
alone
but again the hpd primary screen
still maintains the highest positive
predictive value as well as the negative
predictive value
so again the screening with the
with the hpv primary screening
would result in improved safety and
effective
effectiveness over
the existing guideline supported
strategy
so let's look at the clinical utility of
each strategy and this really puts the
performance of each into perspective to
fully assess each of these algorithms we
really must demonstrate a balance
between benefits and harms
benefits relating to the number of high
grade gray disease detected and harmed
by the surrogate marker
of the number of colposcopies performed
and the efficiency of the algorithms are
further established based on the number
of tests or procedures needed to be
performed per cin3 or greater case
detected
so for the 40
944
women 25 and older included in the
athena studies an equal number of
initial tests would be needed to be
performed if using a psychology only
strategy
by comparison
the primary screening algorithm requires
slightly more first-line screening tests
and this is mainly due to the psychology
triage of non-hpv 16 and 18 positive
high-risk hpv results
but overall it offers a lower ratio of
tests to disease
about 190 versus 240 for psychology
alone
in addition the primers creating
algorithm yields a lower number of
overall copies that needs to be
performed
and because the primer screening
algorithm demonstrates a higher
sensitivity by detecting an increased
number of c in three or greater cases
it also results in nearly half
it also results in nearly half the
number of copies needed to be performed
per c cin3 or greater case detective
which demonstrates a greater
screening efficiency
in comparison
with the co-testing hybrid so keep in
mind it is uh broken down by age where
women 25 to 29 receive an ascis triage
screening algorithm
and those 30 years and older are tested
uh with or co-tested with cytology and
hpv
what we see is
there's the initial number of screening
tests nearly doubled
and keep in mind for both this algorithm
and the hpv primary screening one
that we just spoke about before the hpv
genotyping is actually integrated into
the initial hpv result
so that reflex cytology would or reflex
genotyping
would elevate this the number of
screening tests um
some significantly depending on what the
um
reflex
algorithm chosen
and compared to cyto compared to primary
screening the number of coposcopies that
detect each c in three or greater case
also increases
raising the overall
uh
number of colposcopies needed to be
performed persian 3 or greater
and in the end
because we're still relying on cytology
based screening for women 25 to 29
the sensitivity
of the co-testing hybrid
is inferior to primary screening
algorithms since only
211 cases of cn3 or greater were
actually detected
so with these data
the baseline effectiveness of the
primary screening algorithm
is
well demonstrated
but to further assess the effectiveness
of versus stratification and the safety
of the primary screening algorithm
following a negative cobus hpv test
results data from the three-year
follow-up phase is used
those who did not reach the study end
point of cin2 are greater at baseline
were invited to participate in the
follow-up phase of the study and during
this follow-up women were seen annually
and had both a psychology and hpv test
performed
if they had an abnormal cytology result
they received a coposcopy
and women that had a cin2 or greater
lesion at those follow-up visits
exited this study for treatment
at year three all women remain
remaining in the study were offered an
exit copostate
so hpv testing detects a risk factor for
cervical cancer and risk stratification
should really accurately predict
long-term risk of high-grade disease
beyond a single baseline measure
it's well established that women testing
hpv 16 and or 18 are at an elevated risk
of having an underlying pre-cancerous
lesion
at the time of testing
but further the infections with hpv 16
and 18 also predicts
an elevated long-term risk of developing
hyper disease
well within a three to five year period
and risk stratifies women with hpv
positive results by by 16 and 18
genotyping
offers an algorithm
that allows clinic clinicians to
leverage the high sensitivity of hpv dna
testing
while avoiding unnecessary follow-ups by
pooled hpv testing
so within the pulled hpv positive group
that had about a 10 risk we find both
women at a extremely high risk of cin3
with hpv 16 or hpv 18 positive results
as well as of women
who had a significantly lower risk
at about five percent
uh when testing uh positive for the
other 12 high-risk hpv genotypes and in
fact in the overall population of women
25 years and older
one in four women that tested hpv 16 at
baseline
developed high grade disease within a
three year screening interval or within
a three year interval
and one in nine women
hpv 18 developed cin3 which is much
higher
than the 10 of women positive for the
pooled high-risk hpv results at the
three-year mark
and it should also be noted
that there is there was a very low risk
of cin3 or greater over the three-year
interval
for women testing a cobalt hpv negative
at baseline
and this data i really demonstrate that
the baseline covos hpv results can
successfully predict risk for high grade
disease over this the interval
but the most
critical piece of data
is the significance of the test results
and about the 90 percent of women
in a screening population will actually
test negative
and negative screening results should
provide sufficient reassurance that a
woman is at a low risk
of having an underlying pre-cancerous
lesion
and then a high-grade disease will not
develop within the next screening
interval
the risk of being diagnosed with cin3 or
greater over a three year period for a
woman with a negative cobalt hpv test
result
in the green line
is one half
the risk predicted by negative
psychology results which is fear and
gray
clearly the lower risk associated with a
negative cobus hpv test result
provides greater reassurance
to both the patient and the clinician
that disease will not be diagnosed over
the next three years
and this lower risk for developing cin3
or greater really confirms the safety of
a negative cobus hpv test
and the safety of the use of the cobas
hpv test as a frontline primary
screening uh out as part of a front
as a front line primary screening tests
it's part of a primary screening
algorithm
and so again primary screening
is really
based on on three main factors
what we want to do is ensure that the 90
percent of the screening population
has
are assured that the 90 percent
of women
who tests pre-negative are at a minimal
risk
of progressing or having a high grade
disease over the screening interval
but to also provide the other 10 with
appropriate risk stratification for
action and also identify those women at
the highest risk for immediate follow-up
and potential treatment and management
so
the athena data confirms that high risk
hpv testing with hpv 16 and 18
genotyping is superior to cytology for
first-line primary screening of cervical
cancer
and both negative predictive value and
detecting cervical disease
the cobalt or the primary screening
algorithm utilizing cobus hpv tests
really leverages the high sensitivity of
hpv dna testing
the built in wrist stratification of hpv
16 and 18 genotyping and also the triage
of the high specific
triage with high specificity of cytology
for an optimal balance of cervical
optimal balance of sensitivity and
specificity in cervical cancer screening
it provides a high reassurance that
women with a negative hpv dna result
remains disease free over the three
for three years
it identifies women positive for hpv 16
and 18 who are at the highest risk of
having an underlying cervical pre-cancer
and it also utilized cytology triage of
the 12 other high-risk hpv positives to
maintain
a high
high degree of screening efficiency
and
the cobas hpv test is the only fda
approved option to improve the disease
detection in women age 25-29
so with that um i will
answer any questions
let's see
i don't see any questions that popped in
um
yet
um feel free if there are any questions
on any of the anything i've presented in
in this
presentation or
um
if you have any other general questions
i'd be happy to answer that but
um i thank you all for attending and
watching this
and again i believe that there are
um
my co you have my contact information so
if there's any additional questions that
come
outside of this
particular session
um i would be more than happy to address
those
so
with that
um have a great rest of the day and
again thank you for joining and tuning
in
all right
oh
i just got a question from i'll answer
that really quickly
um so the question was um
what is the platform of these tests so
all the data presented here was based on
the kobats hpv test by roche
so the data was from the athena clinical
trial that consisted of actually over 47
000 women
but most of the data were presented for
those women 25 and older
uh for which was which was really the
general population that was included in
the study and that was about 41 000
women
but it's the cobas hpv pair
all right
thank you again
oh uh one last question the instrument
is the the kobus 4800 system
um
by roche
all right thank you